Hello.
And welcome
to today's episode of Rawkode live. I am
your host Rawkode.
And today we're gonna be taking a look
at TektonCD.
A continuous
build pipeline delivery
software thingy majiggy for Kubernetes.
Before we get started, I just wanna say
thank you to my employer. I work for
a company called Equinix Metal. They are a
bare metal cloud.
They provide the time, the resources for me
to invest in the show and get experts
from the cloud native community to come and
share the technologies they're working on with us
today. So thank you, Equinix Medal. If you
wanna try it out, you can. There's a
$50 code or Rawkode dash live. This will
get you roughly one hundred hours of compute.
So it'll allow you to get a feel
for what bare metal is and how to
leverage it best to your cloud native architectures.
Now today, for looking at Tekton, I am
joined by Kevin McDermott. Kevin is an engineer
at Red Hat and a contributor to the
TektonCD projects. Hey, Kevin. How are you? Hey,
dude. I'm not doing too badly.
Awesome. Do
you wanna take a a few moments to
tell us a little bit about yourself? And
then we'll start talking about Tekton.
So
I work on GitOps at Red Hat. I'm
building out automated
pipelines to allow you to automate
build and deployment into production.
I've
been writing software for thirty years commercially. So
I've been around the block a few times.
But
most of the stuff I read nowadays is
is really centered around helping people get
software from idea into production as quickly and
safely as possible.
At least theoretically, at least.
Awesome. Cool.
So why don't you start by telling us
what is Tekton?
So Tekton
is a project. Been around for, I think,
four, five years now and and it and
it's basic part of it. I don't know.
Maybe not. Not about two years since basic
part. And what it does is is
I I can keep native a cloud native,
Kubernetes native
pod scheduling.
So what do you have a problem with
now? You wanna run a container in Kubernetes?
How do you get another container to wait
for that container to execute?
You can. Right? It's pretty difficult. You have
to do something with Kubernetes or something. And
so Kubernetes
Tekton allows you to specify the order of
things and you can split and and rejoin
processes
to allow you to set up a series
of events
and
containers to to be executed
on a PVC or something like that. So
maybe if you wanna build, like, a a
build pipeline, then you always have to clone
your source code. You might wanna run some
tests, and then you start to build on
top of it.
So if you will have a continuous delivery
pipeline, then Tekton is a cloud native way
of doing it. It's also the kind of
basis for some other projects. So they're forced
to Jenkins X and things like that. They're
building on top of it.
Okay. So,
I mean, one of issues cases is continuous
delivery. Does it also take the same box,
fit in the same market as other services
like like regular Jenkins, like CircleCI, you know,
does it have a, like, I guess, a
crossover and feature set with these ones or
is it slightly different because it runs on
our own Kubernetes clusters?
So how do think? So I think the
biggest difference is that it isn't by itself
system. It's a way of executing containers and
and and getting the results of those containers
so you don't get the kind of
and this is, you know, it's not intended
not intended to be like this at the
moment and there is ongoing work. But you
essentially get the results of executing those containers.
So for example, like, I was saying, we're
doing is we have OpenShift and we have
some kind of nice UIs around them showing
you, like, the results of those and we
can gather up some
results and you can see, like, what pipeline,
what has executed and things like that.
And as you'll see that there there is
a Tekton dashboard which allows you to get
a kind of nice visual representation of this.
Alright. Well, I am looking forward to seeing
this. Tekton is one of those projects that,
you know there are so many projects
in the cloud native ecosystem. And I wanna
be able to play with them all, I
guess, like Pokemon, but it's just finding the
time. So I'm really glad that we got
to take a look at this today. Yep.
Okay.
Sorry, Nico. What you guys said? You know
that when you open up that CNC airplane,
you
just think, woah.
Sorry. I mean, I I like the size
of it now because I'm like, cool. I'm
not gonna run out of content for this
show for a while. So, you know, selfish
reasons. But certainly as an end user, someone
that has to operate stuff in production, it
can be a little bit intimidating.
But for, you know, Tekton solves a lot
of problems and I'm hoping we can demonstrate
that today. Well, you can demonstrate that today.
I just get to sit and enjoy.
Alright. Before we get started, we do have
a couple of comments. So first, hey, Andreas.
How's it going? Wave, wave, wave. And rain.
Hey, rain. How are you?
Okay. So
let's one of the things I like to
do at the start of the show is
just see what was prepared upfront.
And I like that to be as little
as possible. Now nobody wants to watch me
provision a Kubernetes cluster. So that has been
provisioned upfront.
And I have shared the cube contact for
that with Kevin who will be driving most
of the demo today and
batting away all my questions at the same
time, I'm sure.
I'm gonna share your screen. Oh, we got
Oh, that's okay.
We will
da. Cut you off guard. There we go.
So
can we zoom in on that terminal a
little bit? Sure. My eyes are good, but
they're not that good.
Where's that, Luke? I I would go another
six or seven presses maybe.
Okay.
A couple more if you can. Yeah. Okay.
Let me see if we can do this
a couple more.
I know it's gonna be yeah.
Like, that wasn't too bad, is it? I
I think that should be okay. Better than
yeah.
I think that might be okay. Yeah.
Okay.
So what I'm going to do is
so doc, basically, we have a a blank
cluster provided by David. So what we're gonna
do is then we go through the the
things that you need to have installed. If
native things all have,
know, a a big bunch of YAML to
get installed. So the very first part I'm
gonna install is this is just coming from
the the Tekton release documentation
is the pipelines part. So pipelines is slightly
more mature than
triggers and so we can easily do a
simple control apply
and it will source all those resources and
get them coming in.
How nice to be be on clusterable role
bindings. That's probably something we have to fix
at some point. So this is version 0.18
Is that what we consider stable? That's safe
for production people? Yeah. Okay. Yep. Yeah. I
mean,
it's not one point zero yet and there's
no there's no guarantees around stability. So the
next thing we install is triggers. So pipeline
is basically your sequencing mechanism. You you as
you'll see, you can define tasks and you
can define pipelines
and then we can execute those.
Triggers is more about how do you drive
a pipeline. So I'm hoping that we'll get
to today
actually having completed
driving build and push of an image to
Docker Hub
based on a change to GitHub. So let's
see if can get that far. So that's
what triggers is doing. So it's bringing in
a couple of CRs. So it has if
it I mean, as you're gonna see, this
is pretty YAML heavy.
There's a
not a lot of niceness in some of
this,
is why. And then the very final part
of this, I'm going to grab is the
dashboard.
And we do this.
So we've got our dashboard going in. So
dashboard is nice. So as you can see,
the UI for it looks quite quite tasty.
So I'm I know we were talking about
getting a
an increase available for this. I don't know
if you can do that. If not, I'm
very happy to keep proxy it because keep
proxy is quite nice.
Yeah. I think we'll be we'll be keep
proxying.
So don't worry. You're not gonna you're gonna
have to do we could do this very
small because you actually have to see the
screen. That's fine. So let's keep proxy
figure here, then we should be able to
see yeah. There we go. So this dashboard,
so we've got as you can see Do
you have the main on this as well,
please? Sure. Sure.
Is that readable? Yeah? No. I can't read
it yet.
It's a new one. He's good. We're at
200%.
Or maybe I'll bring my screen size. Maybe
not. Wait. Can you see that? Is that
reasonable?
Visible? The menu is not readable, but the
rest is. So I think we're okay. The
menu is not readable by the Yeah. It's
just it's just a bit small. But it's
okay. I think we're okay just now. There's
not much to see. Oh, there we go.
That's perfect. 300 is where we need to
be.
Okay. So very first thing I'm gonna do
second thing I'm gonna do rather is create
a very, very first task. So this is
maybe a very simple task which I'm gonna
put into file.
So then oh.
Let's look at this. So it's a it's
a cube
CR. So we've got this, you know, API
version, part of the GBK stuff. So API
version kind of task, metadata name. So obviously,
name it. I'm gonna put it in the
default namespace just now mostly because it's kinda
simpler to work with. And this task is
a single step that just has a name
called say hello because you can have a
name for these things. It's using Alpine, which
can be obvious, I guess.
And in this case, it's using a script.
So this gets executed
as a shell script on the inside the
container that you pick. So we have we'll
skip shell inside the open and we're gonna
run this. So let's see. So I save
this and
k. I know you hit k apply but
that's okay.
No. It's k create. I don't like k
apply is okay. Okay.
It's regard creation.
So the next so we have this thing.
So we can see if we go to
dashboard,
we're gonna see we now have a hello
world task created 10 ago
and it hasn't yet run. There aren't any
runs for it, so it's not particularly exciting,
but that's okay.
So next thing we do
is I'm gonna create a really simple task
run for this. After this, this just and
all of the materials will be taken about
other
I'll
just open up the the repo that this
is coming from. So let's create
hello world
task run. So the the relationship between these
is, it's kind of like a class and
instance type relationship if you're a programmer. So
you have like a task defined, here's the
things that need to get executed
and the task run is an instance of
that particular one. So if if you're familiar
with Kube, you'll see that we've got a
generate name on this. I don't need to
have a generate name if I wanted to
keep it, then I'd have to go and
delete everything and run it.
And this basically just is a really, simple
thing that says go and execute the hello
world task. You see there's just a text
script.
What we can do is we can do
key, create.
You
do need to use create with generate name,
I think. So
so what we're gonna see here is if
I click on this hello world task, you
can see that it's
doing its thing. It's pulling it and
and we can see that it logged out.
Hello, world. Right? Pretty much what we expected
to see. So that's a really simple case,
think. We need to say, you know, traditional
from KNRC book, where we've got a hello
world is our thing.
So we can also,
there's a command line component part of this
and it's installable through homebrew, it's installable from
the binary releases
and so we can do a TKN
start
hello
world task.
Oops. Oh, task start.
Oh, if we can't if I could actually
type.
Nobody can type with people watching them, that's
just the rule. It's a ticking task start
and so you can see that that's just
created a task run and done the exact
same thing. So we go to our pipeline
runs, our task runs here, we can see
that our second task running and it's not
gonna do anything different. Right? So we can
do that. Tekton is nice because you can
do things like task run
test.
See this? Because these are really just group
resources, which fits in those. And the thing
that I like the most about this is
you can do task run logs last
and it will go and fetch the lot
most recent task run and get you the
logs from those things. And this applies to
pipeline run as well. So we've seen that
you can basically do a really simple task
that's doing something. Nothing too exciting in this.
Okay. Can I just summarize that back and
tell me if I got anything wrong there?
So
what you've done so far is the fans
and the yaml, your task. Your task just
needs a container image which we reuse in
Alpine. We give it whatever name we want.
And then you have the script
at a property and the spec called script,
which can run any command that can happen
as a damage. Yep. So it doesn't do
anything by default. That just creates a definition
of a task. And then the second thing
that you did via the TKN,
we call it Tekken. Tekken. Tekken. I don't
know.
Is there official pronunciation? In fact, there's just
something I didn't ask you as well. What
does what does Tekton mean? Let's answer that
in a second.
So you
then have a task run which can be
applied via YAML or via the Tekken. I'm
gonna call it Tekken command.
And that actually takes the task definition, runs
it as a pod and set up a
container and then gives us the outcome of
that. That's kind of what you've done so
far. Yep. So that's pretty much it. Basically,
your task definition is your class definition if
you like and your task run is an
instance of that class and executes whatever the
behavior that was in the class. That's a
kind of simple way to think about it.
Obviously, there's not a direct analogy but it's
task will not deviate from a a task.
Sorry. Task run will not deviate from a
task.
So tasks that do one single thing are
not actually all that useful, don't suppose.
So what I'm gonna do here is I'm
gonna need to update this task.
I'm gonna give it a parameter because, you
know, sometimes you just want to
sometimes you just want to
okay. So I'm gonna add a parameter. So
you can see that I've added a single
parameter. It's called name because, hey, we're gonna
greet someone here. It's a it's a string
type parameter.
The default is world because, you know, traditional.
And we can give a description so we
can see, like, who is it, what is
it, what's the purpose of this particular parameter.
You can name parameters any which way you
want and you'll see there's bit of variance
between them. Some people use lowercase and some
people use uppercase.
I tend to use a mix sometimes usually
to differentiate between parameters that are the same
because you may become you may be coming
in an input parameter or an output parameter,
but you can choose to name them in
which way you want. And so you can
see that that on
on line 16, you can see params dot
name. So what that's gonna do is when
it gets when the task run gets created,
when it's setting up, it does a param
replace.
And so anything that's getting pulled in is
a params dot name thing here, that will
get replaced with the value of the parameter.
It's just a string replacement. It's it's not
anymore advanced than that. Does that make sense?
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. That makes sense.
I think that's just interpolating the entire script
and dropping in all those parameters before
runtime. Right? Okay.
Yeah. So we can now do Tekton task
start.
Hello world task.
You see that it's gonna say, like, can
give us a value for the parameter name
of type string. So you can create this
with a pipeline run, you can obviously do
it in in in the task run rather.
And you can put it in explicitly into
the ammo. But Tekton
allows you to prompt for those things. So
you can see that it's offering me the
default world.
But, hey, you know, let's put in Rawkode
in there.
Okay. Awesome. So we can do Tekton
task run logs last.
May not have completed yet. Oh, yeah. It
has. Awesome. Right. So you can see that
we've got this Hello Rawkode and that's gonna
be expected. Right? So tasks are really kinda
simple. But tasks can have multiple steps. Let's
you know, we can see where we're going
next to this. So we can we can
create a task once we can pass this
in if we really wanted to do it.
We're not gonna do that. We can change
our so let's add an extra step to
our task. Right? So a task doesn't have
to be just one thing, it can actually
have multiple
I don't even know why that's jumping a
bit all over the place.
With your hello world task dot yamo
add an extra step in here.
Mhmm. What's interesting about it, I guess, the
thing that caught me at the first time
I had to do this was
you that that it uses a different image
for each one. So these are obviously a
complete separate pods on top of this. We
you're gonna see what this gets generated as.
But we can put the same use the
same parameter again,
and this will get executed as a couple
different pods. So if I do Tekton
I think your HTML invalid.
Oh, which actually I think your name, image,
and script are all indented ones based too
many.
Yes. You're absolutely right. See.
That's why I was kinda worried about YAML.
I always worry about YAML.
There's no YAML to it. YAML developer.
Alright. So we've got our task we've been.
So let's do we start on this. Let's
do
live demo.
It will of course get past through
and
oh,
I haven't completed probably.
We go. There are a few things. Okay.
So and of course, if we go into
dashboard,
You can see your tasks coming up here.
There's the the duration of them
and
you can see, you know, which particular pod.
And these these just get executed pods.
Does it show you the parameters that were
passed to it as well?
Good question. I know Tekton does. If I
do Tekton describe
describe
last
I definitely, you can see. So there's your
parameters there. Does that show you the parameters?
Let me see. It would be on oh,
yeah. There you go. So on the actual
task, it's on the container. So you can
actually see those things.
And you can keep them by by by
because obviously, they are pods. So if we
do, like,
pods, you'll see that we have
one pod for each of the and
and so some of those as you can
see, hello world task run two two sevens
eight five has
two
containers with it and that'll be this the
hello and goodbye containers.
Oh. So those actually ran as multiple containers
and a pod concurrently and not one after
the other? No. They run they run one
after the other. They do. Oh, they're good.
Sequence a little bit, but these actually wait.
It uses the downward API to do detection
of when the the things are gonna execute.
But as you will see in a bit
when we get to, like, sequencing of of
pipelines,
yeah, you know, you you actually need it.
For example, if you're gonna have a get
clone task before you run your build, you
really need to make sure that the code
is completed before you start to build your
code. So we'll have a look and see
how that actually happens.
Okay. So where are we? So we're basically
so the other format for this, so we
create a slightly different task here.
The other format you can use
oh, I expected to download a complete, don't
know.
The other format you can use is you
can put like a traditional
YAML array type approach too. So you don't
have to use a script. So you can
actually execute a very specific command with a
specific specific parameters.
So I do git create.
Start to execute l s.
What do I call it?
Hit it. Oh, did I not do it?
Execute
l s. You did a cube create within
them, but I'd that's I'm not sure what
that did.
Let me read and wait for it to
complete before it is it. Let's make sure.
Yeah. Okay. Yeah. There you go. Probably.
And so we can put in so let's
put slash in here.
And
logs was
and it's probably
yeah. There we go. So just exactly what
you'd expect. We just executed. And as you
can see from the task
definition,
it's just the same as everything else. The
the
parameter
interpolation is just getting put into the array
slice of this. There are some complications around
this. So you can have, like, one of
the types you can have is a
an array types parameter
type.
And you you kinda have to go and
pull out the specific elements or there's some
weird stuff around, like,
expand well, expansion
of of array slices of or slices arrays
of
strings.
But you can also it's it's able to
be you can go fetch a specific one
when you can even do those kind of
things. So Yeah. I would that's pretty trivial.
So that's well, you know, just so you
know you're saying what you're gonna have a
point definitions or whatever you're doing. So need
to be thinking about it. So that's that.
We have a question if you're happy to
take that just now. Yeah. Go for it.
Andreas is asking if we'll be covering the
options for building container images.
Yes. We will.
Alright. Stay tuned, Andres. I mean, I mean,
also, we'll see who
so we're gonna use builder to do later,
but I'm sure we will get to that.
So this there's another thing that we have
called
this this is some
so
let's look at this one. So this is
so the difference here is you get a
thing called a result
and the result is something that you
when you execute, if you write to the
path of the result, then whatever you write
there is available to other tasks. Now this
is a single task, so it's not so
exciting.
But first, like, you'll see in a bit,
like, when you clone a git clone, when
the official git clone task, it writes the
specific URL and the shell of the commit
that it cloned
to results, which you can then use later
on. So for example, you may wanna build
something that references
those things and so you can do that.
So this case here is a really simple
example ish.
It takes a repo and it goes to
GitHub and then uses j q to
work out what the most common, you know,
the the the if you go to I
don't know if you go to slash languages
on a repo, then you get this map
back which is the strings of all of
the
languages. You know, when you go to GitHub
and you can see it. So this this
will go into it and we'll put out
the top language. How useful this is? Probably
not all that useful.
But let's
so
good. Let's not wait. Actually, I could create
complete this thing.
There we go. Right. So it's the TTM
task
start
top language
task. And you can actually pass parameters. We
can do recall equals give me a recall
something you've got on GitHub.
Rawkode
slash dot fails
slash
no. Slash in Rawkode slash dot fails. Not
actual little word. Yeah.
Okay. It's Wednesday.
Can you have we hide on that screen
share thing just so it doesn't Sound you.
Pull up the text.
Yeah. It annoys me as well. Oh.
Thanks. Alright. Okay. So we've got a task
run. In task run
logs
past.
It should say, gender, gender, gender.
So it's done. Yeah. Believe it or not.
But with the Tekton task run describe,
Last, you should see the what what language
you expect me to be? Gender.
Michelle. Well, I guess it's calendar too. Right.
So top according to so what it does
is it goes in the like, if you've
never seen j q, j q is fun
for doing this kind of stuff. But you
can see, like, two entries, sort by dot
value dash one, take the last one and
then get the key of that.
So,
like,
you get two for today, you you get
whether JQ works if you're really keen on
it.
I think it was very infectious and get
you. So your your top language and your
repo is clearly shale. So
So you
So
this is using something on a task called
a a result. What what are the primary
use cases for that then? Is that something
we use to to pass it other task
definitions? Is it something
is it logged hand is it logged differently
in the UI? Like, what are what do
we get results for? Use for couple of
different mostly, it's about getting things between
between
tasks in our pipeline.
But you can oops. If I I
remember to actually get the right thing here.
So I get my task room. What was
my what was my task room? You can
I mean, because it's it's a standard
cube resource of object, you can do
this and so you can you know, if
you wanted to run something and then get
a structured result from it, you can do
that? So we we can get our value
back as Shell.
But yeah. I mean, it's it's essentially just
writing a value in that you can then
use later in a pipeline. So for example,
you might
get an auth token, for example, for something.
So you might want to write that to
the result
and then pick that up and use that
for auth and subsequent requests
Because you can as you'll see now, we've
been when we get to pipelines, can actually
reference
results
specifically as parameter and and put them into
parameters
to be then called by subsequent tasks in
the pipeline. Okay. So we actually have another
question that aligns really well to what you
just said there then. Andres is asking,
is there a way to put secrets
into our tasks so that we can access
secret information from Kubernetes or even failments?
Yes.
There's a couple of different ways to do
it. We're gonna see a secret getting used
later.
This is something that I'll be honest, especially
pipeline doesn't have it's not great the support
for doing this
for reasons that you've seen a bit there.
And there is a plan to kind of
make this a little bit better. There's a
there's a big kind of discussion about making
secrets better for pipelines
before one point zero, I guess. But you'll
see how that works in a bit. I
promise we're gonna get to doing a secret.
So I'm gonna create a very simple
pipeline. Okay?
This pipeline here. So let's look at what
this has. So this is a pipeline called
demo pipeline. It takes one parameter,
takes string and it only has one
task in it. Right? So it's using the
task that we were using earlier
called hello world task. It's a task task.
You get two types of tasks, you get
cluster tasks and you get task tasks.
And so we're and it's unsurprisingly, the difference
between those is one is cluster label and
the other is namespace label.
And you can so for example, how you
build
your docker images and things like that. Those
probably don't vary very much across different environments.
So you probably won't make those as a
kind of or or the goal in code
or anything. So I mean, maybe a lot
of tasks I'm gonna show you today are
could be cluster labeled tasks.
But for the specific case, this is we're
just gonna keep them all in one namespace
and and have some point that way, I
guess. And so one of the things that
we see is see that params part in
the task reference,
so just below the task. So what that's
actually doing is it maps a parameter to
the pipeline
to a parameter to the task. So you'll
notice that I deliberately called the parameter to
the pipeline message.
And what it does is it takes that
message value
and maps that to the name parameter to
the task.
That make sense?
Yes. So our our pipeline has a parameter
called message and we're passing that into the
task as name.
Yes. It means you don't have to have,
like, the same names and you you this
is a really common thing through Tekton. There's
a whole lot of things that use remappings,
like workspaces and so
many other things basically you see, like, here
is this value and it and it I'll
be honest, it looks complicated at first and
and if you don't understand the exact reason
for it, it's twice as complicated probably.
But really what it's all about is you
don't need to have standard naming and you
could have pipelines or upstream
have upstream tasks that you just use and
you map how you wanna make your parameters
pass through to those.
Okay? Mhmm. So this is our very first
pipeline. So this is
I need there
we go. Okay. So we can
create what's called a pipeline run.
And to be honest, Tekton
is creating pipeline run. So I'm gonna probably
create a pipeline run.
Oh, no. I'm gonna do it this way.
We're gonna get to pipeline run the things.
So pipeline
start demo pipeline.
It's gonna complete and so probably It's gonna
ask me for the message.
So let's put let's
do our Tekton
pipeline
run list.
Because we we should see it. So you
can see that it's running and
we can do
logs last
and this
wait. There we go. Awesome. Right. So it's
just executing that task.
We're going to our dashboard.
We get to see our pipeline runs for
a change
and we can see this particular
pipeline run here. Yes. So that's it there.
And all it does is one task and
passes that parameter through to it. It's kinda
really simple.
Pipelines basically provide sequencing
for tasks.
Can I don't know if it's something you're
gonna show later, but it popped in my
head? So I'll see now. Can can we
modify this
the task definition and can we make it
fail? Just for the yeah. Yeah. Just for
the giggles?
Okay. Could we do this? Let's think.
What would what would actually call it to
feel?
Let's just change the task to run a
command that doesn't exist. Like, instead of echo
let's type one echo or something. Right? So
Yeah. Let's let's do l six.
Yeah.
I don't think there's a command called l
six, is there?
No. See what I know.
Yeah.
We
do actually. Oh, yeah. So why?
Come on.
On. Okay.
It's
we run that pipeline and you'll see what
happens. So
we start demo pipeline.
Let's
just put demo
see it in there. I
think there we go. Awesome. Right. So it
failed because and then a pipeline will fail
if any of its tasks fail.
As soon as a step, it returns a
non zero exit code, then it fails. I'm
assuming I can just get the logs out
of that, see why it failed. Like, it's
all self explanatory, I would imagine. It's actually
quite nice because you can do if you
do type click again pipeline
run
Last.
See see. See
what I actually say. It's usually says, like,
you know, state state space code 127 blah
blah blah to
see the specific logs for this.
Must have listened like a real oh, because
it's so big. It's getting taken off into
the screen.
If you're in a normal screen, what actually
happens here is it shows you
the the the control command to
display it.
I don't even do a scroller across from
this for whatever reasons. It can't just create
except for when it's not. You can just
show it from the UI, I guess. Right?
I mean Yeah. Yeah. That that message should
be there too. Yep. You'll see that thing
there, but it it it will. Yeah. Perfect.
So we exactly what we expected. If you
modify it and you get I mean, it's
it's really visible. You can see the nice
kinda
red thing here. So this is
we can we can do better. Okay. So
now we're gonna start to get into the
the the image and the other bits of
it that folks are probably really keen on.
So there is a catalog of tasks
available. So Tekton has this
whole big catalogue with
about five different build mechanisms.
It's builder, s two I and build packs
and various other things in here. So these
are kind of predefined
tasks.
And if we go and look at the
get clone task
Can you just send that to 300%?
Yeah. Thank you for reminding me.
So you can see that this has a
0.2
and it has
two things. So this it says here this
task has two required inputs, the URL of
the get reports clone provided with the URL
parameter
and a workspace called output.
Okay. So we can see that these are
the two things.
And we'll talk about workspaces when I set
this up to do it. But based on
our workspaces
I'll say you last thing, so I'll do
it. Workspace is in kind of shared space.
So it's a PVC that's getting defined
and that task executes.
It's because this is why you can't use
an empty door because if you did, you
would end up with multiple
p v empty door PVCs getting created. And
this gives you kind of persistent storage to
it's bound to the lifetime of the pipeline
run to be fair,
but I lose the, like, tasks to carry
the things. So obviously, if you get cloned,
you probably want to act on that get
cloned that you've just cloned. So what this
allows you to do is to write it
out and then have another task come along
and pick that source code up and do
the right thing. So there's a whole lot
of parameters. I'm not gonna go into all
of them. You can see that
you can provide revisions, rest specs,
sub modules, depth, SSL verification,
which I think should be insecure as you
know, and I don't like CSSL verified. What
what it tells you and what it what
it mean is really different. You can set
up properties and things like that. So you
can do a lot of different things in
So what we're gonna do is we're gonna
take
the this is the YAML for it.
It's quite a big task here. I've looked
at it a few things. Come on. Go
to there. And you can see it's got
a 32 lanes. Probably not what you wanna
look at. So I'm gonna grab the raw
version of this.
Uh-huh. So the way that we use we
consume tasks from the catalog, it's it's really
just to apply them rather than, like, reference
them within the YAML itself. Yeah. Because it's
gonna be in the industry. There is
a couple of things. So I'm
pretty sure Tekton has support for fixing them
from
from the catalog.
But there's also a big bundle work going
on, some quick site and stuff going on
that's always you to, like, bundling to,
like, add all of the various pieces that
you might need for a task. So there
we go. So we've installed our new and
get clone task as you saw from the
the catalog.
That's what I'm now about to do
here
is I'm gonna build a pipeline that uses
this.
Okay. So it's
then
go to the old source.
That was a better promise if ever I
heard.
Build source pipeline.
What you're gonna see is it takes two
parameters. I've made them capitals mostly to help
differentiate
between the things that I'm passing in and
the things that the task needs. You'll notice
that in the past, the task said it
needed a lowercase URL and a lowercase revision
parameter.
So my pipeline takes Git repo and Git
ref
and it
takes those and and will execute the task.
You can see that it creates this it
uses, I think, called a work space. So
this is like a declaration. So this is
I see that this pipeline has a workspace
called shared data.
But again, this mapping thing that we talked
about, like, workspaces name output, workspace shared data,
that's me saying that the, git clone source,
which is using git clone,
it should, get this shared data workspace, but
they want to call it output for their
purposes. So that's cool. We will we will
map shared data to output for the execution
of this particular task.
Okay. So that's like, basically, a pipeline with
a single task just now. All it's doing
is calling that get repo
and putting it in.
So
I'm gonna build
a source.
I'm gonna do
it like this.
Oh,
yes.
Oh, you didn't apply the pipeline.
Right. Okay.
So it's a you know, handy here. So
name for the workspace
should be the
this
I mean, we can empty there for this
one because we can we don't need to
carry the source across.
So it's an empty door, isn't it?
Think this will work.
Okay. So it's gonna go and grab the
git clone task
and do the right thing.
You can see that it has completed. Awesome.
Right. So not particularly useful as a start,
but
log slash.
You'll see that we
awesome.
So that's stored in there and
that's our that's our first problem when we
wanna whenever you wanna build something, you need
to you need to source code somewhere.
Okay. So one of the things I'm gonna
show, we've talked about earlier is task results.
Let me
see what they're useful for.
Oops. So they're bigger. So I'm gonna add
an extra task in here
and well, this is two things. Right? So
this new task is called echo results.
Number of easier to people to 26,
you can see echo results. And so what
you'll notice is I've explicitly put it to
run after clone source
and I'm happy to take that out and
show you what happens if you don't put
running after.
But you can see that it's
taking two parameters, the commit in the URL
and
it's got a script that just echoes the
two values. Right? So nothing particularly remarkable about
this particular thing.
But it takes its parameters to the task.
This is like an embedded task. I'm not
referencing an external task here. I'm referencing an
embedded task
and it's gonna take those two parameters. So
you see the way that this is referenced
here. So this tasks dot clone source dot
result dot commit. Unfortunately,
the only way you'll know this is by
looking at the task that you're executing,
but this is seeing that lane 14 task
clone source,
it has a result called commit and I
want to be passing that and it's a
parameter
to
my echo results
task. Does that make sense?
Yeah. I mean, I'll try and summarize that
back to you. So this is another pipeline
with multiple tasks. I think what's different from
this one
is that instead of using task ref like
we do in the clone source one, we
got a task spec. The task spec just
allows us to define a task inside of
the pipeline.
There's an access to a variable called tasks
dot and then the code source is just
the name of the previous task. And then
we can access the results and then the
commit and then the results of the URL
from it. So all connect links together via
the task name and
the task back is a nice way to
know that. I mean, is task back something
that you see
people using for their pipeline trial and find
the task separately? Is there any kind of
preference there?
So,
truthfully, guess it depends on whether you consider
a task to be reusable or not. Like,
for some things. For that, why did I
put a task back in here? Because basically,
I didn't want to write another YAML file.
Don't have to find it. Then I can
just do how much task is taken. So
that's what I was doing too, like
I guess if it's reusable and if you
and and it's easy enough to refactor this
so you can just extract it and make
that task speak the speak of a task
definition that you're rating.
So nothing would be particularly different here and
we're just the only thing that we've changed
is task speak and become task ref and
whatever you name this.
Yeah. So it's really it's a useful trick.
It's I I guess, the paintings are kind
of when we generate, like, paintings for the
time for this.
We cannot try to mostly task ref but
for some cases, we would task make it.
And if you've tried my Tekton CI thing,
it generates huge gamos
with all embedded tasks and pipeline runs in
the rhythm. What I'm gonna do here
is
we do keep a play on it.
I should have done when it was in
boom, but there you go.
K. And I'm gonna run that pipeline again.
Me know what works. I will see how
it goes.
There's
in task run logs.
And what I'm gonna do, once it's failed,
once it finishes,
I'll go back and show what happens if
you don't put one after because this is
this is sequencing. Right? So you need to
wait for the first task to finish
generally.
And so, Tekton.
I pick my mom.
Oh, yeah. So you can like pick from
here. That's pretty cool.
Should see and there we go. Right. So
our our task is executed
and all it says you can see, it's
just echoed the two values that we were
expecting to get here. It's nothing
don't think about that. Okay. So
we're gonna start to get into building an
image from source. So there's another task
and Do you want to remove that run
after first? Just so we can see. Oh,
yeah. Yeah. Yeah. I
was excited for that and then I felt
like you were gonna take away from me
there.
Right. So we do this
and go
go ahead and use them for everything.
So it should apply that. There we go.
Let's do that run again.
Oh.
Yeah. I don't know why it doesn't just
default to that. It's possibly a bug. Anyway,
so we're gonna do this.
I think it will know
I
think it's a bit confusing because it's not
obvious. We give you
oh, yeah. Yeah. It's p t n task.
It could get result.
Think
this may just be let me see. Oh,
did I actually reapply that thing after I
changed it?
I don't recall.
How much I I think it may just
be lucky.
So is there a race condition without the
run after? Okay. Yep. We can get into
it. Let's say you avoid race conditions.
And so,
builder is this new task that we're gonna
use. Right? So builder takes a git repository
that has a a Docker file in it
and
it it builds it and then pushes it
to git repository.
So this is kinda really so it's it's
an image repo. So you can see that
you've you've got given an image, override the
builder image,
the path to the Dockerfile. So that just
kinda assumes that it'll be in the top
label of your
repo.
You can pass a whole of extra parameters
and and arguments to it. So for example,
you wanna add them, we we will be
using this for is for doing extra
labels on an image. So if wanna, like,
label it with a commit and who committed
and the details that can be getting from
a
commit here. So you can see that it's
gonna take a source
and it's gonna work on top of that.
So
I'm gonna steal my
oh, yeah. I'm do it like this. So
first of all, I'm gonna do the the
apply.
So
that'll work.
Awesome.
I will need a secret
in your
k. So I've got a secret created. And
what I'm gonna do for this is I'm
gonna grant access to that secret, the Docker
config secret type. So I'm gonna add
this to the
default service account, which is probably not that
great, anyway, we'll come back to this thing.
And
I'm gonna need so
let's
oh, source pipeline.
So
let's look at what we've got now.
We have
task clone source
and we have a task build image and
build image runs after closed source. References the
task, the build image and it takes our
param image
that we wanna do. And
it's pretty pretty simple.
Builder, as I say, just takes your Dockerfile
and runs, I think, called Builder, which is
our bug rather, which is our tool for
building images inside containers.
Yep.
So if we do key,
it's
deviation for control to key.
And so let's run this builds.
I need a secret. There's reason I need
a secret in there is because I wanna
which image to
it could be the
I demo
latest.
That should work.
Yeah.
Yeah. Now this might take a little bit
of time. Yeah. Sure. Put some there.
Let's see. See that this is pro oh,
parameter missing. Oh,
I know what I did wrong.
Well, we let's see what this is. Then,
really, let's let's say, he can
pick
actually, the parameters I'm screwed on.
Last
thing, you see it's missing the image param.
So pipeline run to full parameters. It's missing
some parameter. It's missing some parameters source
image. If you look at my command line,
minus p is how you specify each key
value parameter.
And I forgot what p I need there.
So that's cool.
So it keeps asking you for the workspace,
the sub path. I mean, is there a
way for it to not ask that?
Oh, I can't think about I don't know
where we have it on Tekton. So the
way I normally do this is by creating
a pipeline run and just as I did
with the task running earlier and you can
then do the whole thing and then you're
just kinda creating it because it doesn't change
over the noise cycle. Oh, there's a nice
typo there actually,
which I haven't noticed before and it's empty
here.
Okay.
Well, maybe fix that.
Yeah. You take it someone who took
in and
pipeline run
logs last.
Running, so this might take a little bit
of time. Oh, yeah. I mean, that's actually
building that container image with both on there.
Right? So Yeah. Yeah. I mean, I think
maybe
looking about a minute or so. Oh. Oh,
no.
I've I've been in the what it is.
You get code succeeded.
No Docker file? Yeah. Great. So I know
what it is. So this is
I'm gonna build this is we do need
a pipeline run for this because
it's multiple
containers.
I think that this is really just a
limitation of Tekton. Just now, had a conversation
here since I'm in didn't quite get what
I was going. So so what I'm gonna
do here is I'm gonna write a pipe
I've got a pipeline run ready for this.
K. So let's do pipe build source pipeline
run dot yamo.
Mhmm. What I'm gonna do is here, gonna
create what's called a volume clean template.
And that's
what it really is is a way to
clean a bit of your PVC space. Right?
So I'm just gonna grab a gigabyte. Sorry.
Dude, if you get more of that, you're
at least not more in trouble.
And then we change
this
to push it to
it's gonna do all the same things. Right?
It's nothing not any different from the PV.
It's say for this, it's gonna provide
PCB
back into and if if you think about
it, empty doors are for the light span
of the pod
because we have multiple pods when we for
each of the the steps or each of
the tasks
and we are
okay. Create I guess if almost like a
pound doesn't fancy.
So we have a question which I think
fits some of what you're doing right now
as well. So just to clarify,
the PVC template,
the shared data
PVC that we're sharing across the pipeline is
specific to that run of the pipeline. Is
that right? Yes. So Andreas is
Andreas is just asking, is there a way
for us to actually have global state that
we can inject onto multiple
pipelines for cache libraries? I guess, like, composer
caches from PHP, pypi from Python. Yes. You
can.
So you don't if you don't use a
template so what so there's two different ways
to specify a volume for a a pipeline
run. You can be explicit
and actually just reference a volume and and
and the get clone task will allow you
to get code even if the content already
exists. You can create a parameter option to
that. So you could share the same p
b c and do a git clone and
then, you know, cache and see if use
an order or something like that. You could
cache the the results in with that. So,
yes, you either got templates which are created
and are tied to the lifespan of the
pipeline run or you have a fixed volume
and you can just mount that in any
pipeline run that you want. Nice.
So let's see where are we. Let's see
where are we. Where are we? We're still
running. We
oh, wow. It's quite impressively. That's hardware you've
got running at it. Parmel Parmel is the
only way you run Kubernetes.
I'm not I'm I'm not even doing that
for a week, you know. And so let's
go
oh, I've got to log in to hub.docker.com.
Here, this is not gonna be fun.
Okay. You just have to trust me on
this. There's a Christian image.
This is gonna create a whole new profile,
so I didn't have more my history. Not
that my history really That
is actually pushed to the to the docker
hub. Right? With your credentials.
I mean, you don't need to show us
that, but I guess you just created a
secret inside the the cluster that Tekton has
access to. Yes. Okay. That's why I choose
that earlier. So, basically,
you did that here, you you saw the
thing where did it, right, so you can
do it here. Right? So create a secret
from your from home Docker config JSON. Right?
So it needs to a Docker config JSON.
Yep. And Tekton will automatically make sure that
that's available as your config JSON, which is
you're off to pushing up to GitHub.
GitHub or to whatever your your thing is.
And so, essentially, it takes the secrets that
are associated with the service account that's actually
doing the work
and we'll we'll bind those things.
So it's kind of fairly simple. So we
got our image, but I mean, as you
can see, it didn't take all that long
to build, did all of the Dockerfile
compilation
we're good to go there. Okay. So that's
the so let's I'm gonna do one other
thing here. Right? So what I'm gonna do
is I'm gonna add a a test task
in. It's what I call this code.
Go test task dot yamo. So it's because,
you know, generally, you don't just build code,
you probably went all into it beforehand.
So what I've got here is a really,
really simple
go test task. So what does it do?
Does a mod setup to make sure that
all of our things are pulled.
It runs GoVet. It runs CILint and then
it runs go test on the source code.
And so if any of those things
fail, then we want our pipeline to fail.
We don't wanna build the image if, you
know, if the code's not good. So what
I'm gonna do is oops. I'm gonna do
a kube
create.
K. So this is gonna create that task
for us.
And then what I'm gonna do is I'm
gonna go to the pipeline, which is the
build.
I'm
going to
here.
Almost do this one by hand.
But then if I if I screw it
up, I'll spend ten minutes trying to figure
it. So let's put this in. So I've
said that check sources, check source should run
after clone source
and it it just maps in the thing
here. But what I want build image to
do is to run after check.
So k. So we've got the sequence. We're
seeing it. Clone it,
check it,
build the image. That makes sense? Yeah. Pretty
pretty standard
build process, I guess, for most people. Yep.
It's okay.
Yeah.
K. So now we'll just wanna we'll get
a new pipeline run.
We would be
yes. Here.
Do Tekton pass by they should hopefully feed.
Yeah. I'm going to feed.
And the filling test,
which we used to show how to get
up. And we're we're doing okay for time,
I think. Yeah. Maybe we'll get there.
Let's keep that first.
So can you just run
keep control get task run? What that also
works. Right? I mean, are all just CRDs.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. I see.
Let me get there. Yes. Cool. I like
it. Yeah. So we I mean, they are
just CRs. Tekton is nice because it gives
obviously some
localized knowledge to the the actual output of
the things. But ultimately, you can just
the right thing. So let's see. Where are
we? Oh, where were the task room listed
here?
Oh.
Yep. So it's still running.
It's right. I guess it's in a bit
a bit more last time, isn't it? Mine
as well. I guess I mean, is there
a way for us to find out what
what task is on right now if it's
on the the the run?
Yeah.
Should be able to see
awesome.
Right. So our code is broken.
Deliberately so I promise. Your code is broken.
Mine's the same.
Okay. My code is broken.
So we will come back to fixing this
once we start to go down the event
listener and we'll see how we can by
pushing this, we can trigger a new build
automatically.
So it's easy enough to insert tasks into
the pipeline. And what you'll notice is if
we look at it,
that it didn't execute the image build. Right?
So you can see that it it did
the clone, it did the go there, it
did the go test,
and then it failed at that point. And
if we go to the dashboard,
and look at our pipeline runs, you can
see that it builds towards pipeline
and it has field.
So you can see that it got where
it got to and which bit field. It's
quite nice.
Dashboard is nice. TKN is nice.
Almost all of these things are just providing
views of the cube resources as you can
imagine. K. So all that's quite cool.
So what do I wanna do next? Great.
Well, we're gonna look at
an event listener. An event listeners are part
of Tekton triggers, so they're the kind of
other side of this. So the very first
thing I'm going to do, I'm going because
I'm gonna cheat a little bit here. Right?
So I'm gonna grab this permissions dot yamo.
Really, this is permissions to allow Tekton
to execute
containers
in the default namespace. You always have to
go to Tekton pipeline's namespace.
But there's reasons for, like, it's just easier
to cheat like this. So we need to
do a keep a control apply. You can
go and grab the permissions if you want
to. You see it's create demo role and
a demo cluster role and a demo role
being done and a demo service account. There's
nothing
tremendously remarkable here. So what I'm gonna do
is
I'm gonna grab this event listener.
So let's look at what this is. So
this is an event listener. So an event
listener is basically a way for ingress for
for JSON
bodies to come in and to trigger something.
So what does it trigger? Well, in this
case, there's no filter. Okay? So we just
get this thing that says whenever you get
something that comes in,
use the bindings, which we're gonna see in
a second.
In fact, I should probably bind them all
together in one file. No. I won't do
it with that.
You can see how that could go badly
wrong.
So we've got this binding
and template. So once you see what a
binding looks like, these make a bit more
sense. I'm gonna steal it in here.
Binding demo. So
metadata demo binding.
And so this is our our main binding,
which we referenced in the the event listener.
And
so this is, whenever you get it, go
and extract. So what we're gonna do here
is this this thing here, body is adjacent
path specification. So this is go and get
the body which is provided as the JSON
whatever the HTTP body only works with JSON,
though, because let me remember. It doesn't support
anything other than JSON. Yes. So this is
what the JSON
body that you receive will have a message
key at the top label order. So extract
that out into a parameter called message.
Alright? So that's kind of obvious what that's
doing.
And then we're gonna create this template. So
templates are a bit weird because they are
very powerful,
but also,
please.
So what this is is
this template needs a parameter called message.
It's just a description message. I was really
bored earlier. You can tell.
Right? So we got resource templates and so
the resource templates are
think of these like like YAMLs for pipeline
runs and things like that.
And the only difference is they get dynamically
evaluated
when the
trigger is executing
correctly. So in other words, and what it
really does is it extracts the values from
the event listener. So it's it's from the
binding,
well, so it's demo binding.
So it extracts that and then it puts
it into the pipeline. So this thing here,
t t, so trigger template dot params dot
message.
Okay. So it's gonna call our demo pipe
in from earlier, the one that didn't do
very much. It just passed through hello world
and
it's going to apply
a pipeline run for it and extract the
body from some JSON body that we're gonna
fire at it and execute that pipeline. Instead
of doing, like, t k and run and
put in a parameter,
we can do the whole thing. So let's
do t,
apply minus f demo
template.
This is gonna be boring. I can see
why I was thinking of doing it. Binding.
So remember.
We've now got this thing. So let's do
k get all.
K get pods would have been poor.
Actually, services would have been even
so we can see that we've got this
EL demo event listener here.
Yep. Okay. So it's listening on port eighty
eighty.
And so this basically waits for HTTP requests
to come in. So what I'm gonna do
is I'm gonna very quickly do another very
key port forward. Do I have to be
to read this one?
Service,
Yale
demo event,
listener,
80.
Should do yep. Okay.
And what we're gonna do is we're gonna
need
Carl to send the body.
Okay. So you can see that this is
gonna be content type application JSON. Message is
coming from JSON to HTTP local host eighty
eighty.
Okay.
So if we know
Tekton
pipeline run
west,
should see oh, do we we broke it
earlier, didn't we? We did.
And we didn't put it back. Okay. Well,
here we go. But I debug it in
there. Have to get in pipeline run.
I
Probably still trying to run the the field
dash Rawkode command.
Absolutely.
Tim.
So we we have a couple more comments
while you fix that So
first, Thomas says, hey. Hey, Thomas. Nice to
see you.
We then got Vincent who says we can
pass dash f to follow the live logs
of a task run pipeline run, I guess,
which is cool.
And then Andres is asking,
is it possible to run build without being
a privileged container?
There is ruthless
builder.
So it's definitely possible.
However, I'm assuming Vincent maybe works on the
Tekton project.
He's also just said that that there's some
limitations with the current version of the task,
but that's about to change. So it sounds
like rootless container
building container image building with builder is coming
soon, which is cool.
So params.
Name, I think.
We're getting some more security.
I should admit you break that task earlier.
I'm sorry. Mean,
debugging is hard. Like, well, I mean, so
we're gonna get our Tekton pipeline run.
This and we should see it being successful.
I think it's right. So this time,
as you can guess, because the JSON says
from JSON, we're gonna do Tekton
pipeline
run logs
last.
And you should see
k. So
if we do a quick
k. Get log
deploy
l demo event.
See what actually logged out. So
and this is for debugging. Right? So you
you you you're getting I'm debugging things. So
it says here, like, it it created a
resource Tekton dev v one beta resource
with a message name from JSON. You can
see that this is the kind resource stuff.
If it fails,
you will get messages in here complaining bitterly
about whatever the problem is that you've just
triggered.
Usually,
the one area that it can be difficult
to debug
is if you're not totally familiar with the
body, the JSON body that's coming in and
you're gonna come I'm gonna come on to
show you some more like, cooler bits of
this. We'll go for another five minutes and
see how far we get. So basically, we
have it and we're running pipelines from things.
So there is a thing here
called the GitHub interceptor
And what it does is
it takes,
like, GitHub push events and allows you to
off them and then decide that you only
want to run on a push event. Okay?
So what we can do
is let me we yeah. We'll see how
do for time here. Right? So we've got
a very quick one.
So this just means that we can use
this GitHub interceptor that whenever we merge to
the main branch, we send something to Tekton,
which triggers the trigger. Yes. So this here
says
use the demo account.
So you then get so what this is
gonna do is also gonna validate the web
hook come from GitHub. Right? So it's like
the secret name and secret token here are
ways of saying that the, you know, that
web GitHub can sign
the
the body of the web of the request
and so it sends you a push event.
So this kind of thing here says, like,
you know, make sure that it's coming from
GitHub with our shared secret and it's a
push event.
And we'll give you a slightly different template
and binding. So let's go with the
in here.
Called it.
One of the nice things about this though
is that you can make this kinda compatible
with multiple
upstreams.
Right? So when you think about it, GitLab
uses pretty different JSON bodies,
but it's the same values that really like
a commit and a URL or the kind
of things we're gonna get from it. So
you can actually
kind of write a standard
build template,
but but how you can get the parameters
to run that template can be different. So
we've got our page. So this is basically,
like, body head commit ID and body repository
call neural. So these come from
this. So you can see, like, if we
look at the push event
commit
just
a little bit more.
Yep. There we go.
So let's see what we get. We're getting
body dot head commit. So if we look
at head commit,
you can see you're gonna get, like, an
ID coming in. Yeah. So we're gonna get
a SHA and they get repository URL. So
we're gonna we'll get clone URL. So that's
actually get it from the hook event, like,
coming in if we want to. Yep.
The last part of this work here, and
we're hoping to get this build finished,
so we can fix this for build, will
be
build code template.
This
here,
I think it
there we go.
So this is a template that is gonna
extract the
oh.
Yeah. Yeah. It's okay. I'm just checking something.
So this is gonna extract the image,
the the the repo, the ref from the
hook request
and then put the image.
You can't really hear there are you can
with a more advanced thing that I'm probably
not gonna get time to get to today,
but that's okay.
But you can actually use like sale to
extract some of these fields and then use
that to to work out which image that
you want to touch the to where to.
But we can see that we're gonna get
some bits extracted from the binding
and it's gonna put it in
k. So what I'm going to do is
k. Get
I'm gonna do that real listener so I
can
And then I'm gonna bring it in and
look, and then we'll see if we can
get a build from a push with GitHub.
Cool. How we how long we got? Two,
three minutes? Okay. It's okay.
Wait. Yeah. Oh, demo.
Cool. And so, k, create that was k.
Create build code template.
Definitely,
it'd been even cooler, wouldn't it?
Yeah.
Cool. Main safe GitHub
push binding
and create main safe GitHub event listener.
Remember that the GitHub event listener is
really just the only difference between that and
the previous one is we've got this interceptor
that's saying, like, only allow GitHub requests that
have a valid secret and that are push
events to come through here.
Okay? You can it doesn't have support for
picking out branches
or any of that kind of thing.
You can do that. Don't worry about it,
but not with the the GitHub secret not
with the GitHub interceptor.
And what it says is like and so
an interceptor basically says, if any these return
an error, then don't use this trigger and
you can have multiple triggers. You see, this
can be duplicated as many things as you
want with different templates and different bindings
and you just detect which one you care
about and then execute. So all of the
ones that where the interceptors don't reject the
request will execute. So if you've got, like,
50 inter triggers in there then, you know,
50 could actually start to execute at the
same time. Yep. But
probably you don't because you filter them out.
And I can write my own interceptors. Is
that
think I
mean, there's I mean, in for that actually.
To be honest, sale will probably cover about
90%
of your use cases. So there's a Google
expression language called c l or sale.
I'm gonna run
the
run the service that was running.
So
you can do it like that. So let
me just do a quick end drop.
Oh, yeah. That should be okay. I will
restart that. What I'm gonna do
is
what's my my port here?
Oh, it's not yeah. It's not it's k
get
services.
Right now, Kevin's just angry, because you want
to be able to have to get a
hub event go to your machine and be
forwarded onto the Kubernetes cluster, because I gave
you a Kubernetes cluster with no ingress.
Yeah. But don't worry about it. Doesn't make
you a bad person, dude.
So let's go go demo.
Let's go to
this is so big. It's really well.
It looks great for us though, Kevin. So
You
know, for me it's like, where are we
really
so let me
oops. Let's see. Let's see. So let's do
this.
P load URL. So this is, as you
can see, just a standard webhook
and GitHub.
So what did my what did Ingram get
me? It got me
I run Ingram. Yes. Let's grab that.
Here's in the darkness.
There we go. Come on. Oh, jeez. This
is hard. There we go.
That yeah.
Or not. That's it. Got it. Okay. So
let me pop that in here.
In
secret, because I happen to know what that
is. And so this is just like, you
know, push events and and things like that.
So Yep. That's gonna be cool.
So if you remember right, we there was
a bug earlier
in the test. Remember the code that was
failing to do it? So what I'm gonna
do
is I'm gonna do git checkout minus b
fix
demo.
Package
demo
handler
test.
Let me see. So is written for another
thing.
So what we see is f
radius URL
equals empty,
key dot skip.
I'm gonna make this return empty if there's
nothing.
I don't really care about it. So let's
say go test up and make sure that
actually runs in between them.
See that in there? So we can, you
know, that's good. Right? So let's do git.git
commit. Mainstream.
Text stuff.
Push. It's gonna complain. Get get push.
I should really see it there as an
option. Yep.
Had it at some point and then every
time I change machine
Right. So I've just done a push. So
if we go to our web hook in
in giant form,
we should see a recent delivery. Excellent. Right.
So that means it's it's simply push on
to Ingrok.
Ingrok will then take that and forward it
to your
bare metal cloud thing.
And now,
if we do Tekton,
Tekton run this.
It's awesome. It's building a source. Right? So
Tekton, Tekton run,
logs. This could take about what? Forty seconds
or something like that.
Add the dash f flag and we'll follow
along. Let's see if that works. Yeah. Thanks.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
Can we do that one there?
Awesome.
So you can see that it's gonna run
the test and see the field maybe or
not. Thank you, Vincent.
I was chatting to you yesterday anyway.
Right. So, you know, our tests are now
passed. Test has passed. Yep. So it's going
to the build. The build. Build. Yep.
There we go. Nice. Very cool.
So we're at fifteen nineteen.
That's not too bad for him. We'll probably
finish out of that. If you're really keen,
I can do a second part of it.
There's all the other stuff that do. So
we sell and stuff like that. But we,
you know, an hour and fifteen minutes is
probably long enough for most people's attention span.
This is good. Good. Get registered to UBI.
I mean, we can fix that.
Yeah. That's awesome. Really really cool.
Great. So we just pushed them. So what
we did there was we configured
Tekton to receive so let's go back and
look at our our things. We
we
have
GitHub event listener.
So it will check for pushes and it
will validate the incoming hooks.
It then hands that off to the GitHub
push binding.
That's what you're pulling out the commit and
the clone URL.
That then goes to the github to the
build codes. I call it I tried to
call it that to to see that it
really is kind of generic as long as
you can get a git ref to it
and a source URL,
then it can create a build
for you. So you can see that that
then passed through and and did the right
thing,
creates a volume and and does all the
things.
This is let's go look at our on
our dashboard.
We should see our pipeline running here.
There we go. One build source. So it
took about a minute and thirty nine seconds
to build. It's not too bad actually.
And that's including all of the checks and
things like that.
Alright.
Perfect.
You know, we got to we did get
to build in source code from
from a git push which was what I
was aiming for. Trust me, I had like
I always stuff like sale interceptors debugging
Versus code Versus code is quite nice on
this. You get like some pretty cool UI,
shows all the tasks and the pipelines.
Or what I believe is a pretty cool
UI for Versus code.
That's alright.
Is there anything else you wanna show before
I pop your screen off? No. No. I
think we'll Alright.
So that was that was awesome. It really
could see Tekton working start to finish including
that. Get help where put coming in, building,
pushing,
all of that. The PVs for carrying the
state, the sequential ordering. Lots of really useful
information there. So thank you for putting that
together. For the people watching, the guest and
the repositories
that Kevin's used will stack in the show
notes so you'll be able to follow along.
And I think we can just finish with
a very brief question then that we didn't
ask at the start is what does Tekton
mean?
So it's
ancient Greek for craftsman
or artisan
and so, like, you know, don't keep a
Greek name for things when you're building a
a docker thing. Either that or some weird
ship related
they
opted for an ancient Greek for craftsman.
Yeah. It's just kinda nice to see. We
must be running a nautical puns for names
or products by now anyway. So
alright. Well, thank you very much. I know
we went a little bit over. I think
you've you've taken time out of your day
for that. So just, you know, thank you
very much for joining us, for sharing that.
I hope you have an awesome rest of
your day, and I'll hopefully speak to you
again soon, Kevin. Thank you. Thank you. Bye.
Cheers. Bye.